hi my name is shannon dang and i play
althea shen hi my name is gavin
stenhouse and i play evan hartley
hey my name is tony chung and i play
dennis stone hello i'm
john priscilla and i play ryan chen hey
there my name is eddie liu and i play
henry anne
hi i'm olivia and i play nicky shen on
kung fu and we're here with buzzfeed
today
to play a game of who's who and i think
i'm gonna get exposed
[Music]
who's most likely to be caught napping
in between
there are some incriminating photos of
shannon like sitting
laying on a bean bag like making sure
her hair is perfect
she just sits there like totally
paralyzed it's it's hilarious
yeah it is high without a shadow of
doubt you'll go back to the green room
and he will be asleep
who's most likely to be found at craft
services
i think actually that makes sense
because i've i've gotten a lot of really
good crafty tips from shannon
shannon olivia yes i feel like you're a
big fan of chips
i agree olivia loves the chips
she has an encyclopedic knowledge of
chips like
she knows every chip brand every like
sub chip brand it's incredible
in non-cova times it would a thousand
percent be me like i would just
go to crafty but because we can't just
go there and like grab
our stuff ourself anymore it's really
embarrassing to go up and be like hey
can i get the goldfish and
two sandwiches those gummies and do you
have any chips also some trail mix who's
most likely to break out into martial
arts on set
olivia eddie wait did you guys both say
eddie eddie does love his martial arts
that is true
so shannon and olivia i feel like it's a
bit of a tie i feel like i've been mime
kicked and
punched like multiple times by olivia so
we'll call it
that i'm training who is most likely to
pull
a prank on set john wait maybe 100
yes he hasn't but we're asking who's
most likely
john definitely john we can't be in the
same scene together
i feel like john would also say john i
am the most professional person
ever he takes the walkies and he's like
rolling rolling rolling
and that's lunch you don't need to
expose me on that as a side note a good
prankster will
never be caught so i'm just gonna put
that there who's most likely to break
character during a take olivia
i'm horrible olivia olivia
is so funny she cracks up about the like
littlest things it's like an inside joke
that we talked about like
a few days ago and then it'll remind her
of something and then she'll just go
i'm laughing in my coverage i'm laughing
in other people's coverage
because i'm present okay and i'm
listening and i'm reacting
but no it doesn't help that i also have
like this old man wheezing laugh where
it's like
who's most likely to nail the scene in
one take
olivia dang oh oh
true kang this guy i mean i don't want
to like
look at me i'm on i'm on a suitcase i
just have to roll away from you
not one but two thumbs up this guy
you're right probably okay yeah love you
it's king who is most likely to brighten
your day vanessa gavin whoa
wow nobody's wrong
olivia yvonne oh yeah tony i'd say you
i said olivia we play sisters and so i
feel like we already have all these like
sister little like nuances of like we
don't even speak words sometimes
sometimes we just make noises to each
other and it's like
who's most likely to be found at the gym
gavin
evan gavin you guys will see why stay
tuned
gavin gavin because i take my gym
everywhere i go
right before this call gavin was
educating me i i had
asked him you know i have this shirtless
scene coming up and you know
he had killed it with his shirtless
scene and i wanted to know his
his secrets and he just spilled them all
out to me and it's so helpful and
and and i'm so grateful gavin is my hero
who's most likely to invite everyone
over for dinner
she even has a little glow plaque that
says mama kane's kitchen
and we always joke that we don't eat
unless mama kane cooks
so we haven't eaten since last week but
i would say
shannon is a close second because
shannon's a great host and she loves
having people over as well
okay yes shannon too kang loves to host
it but shannon she loves
to make the events she does she's the
idea woman
who's most likely to be caught taking a
selfie
yeah it's probably me i also like to
take pictures of other people
so she does no that's so true but if i
ask someone to take a photo
of me it's usually after i've already
taken a photo of them so it could be
seen as selfish i'm like
hey do you want a photo of you like
stand there oh it's great
i'll do the photography for them and
they'll be like by the way can you do me
now
shannon shannon eddie sharon
shannon doesn't take selfies she makes
other people take the photo
she'll like shove her phone at you and
be like take a photo of us but eddie
is a technical way he'll be like okay
guys ready
i do what's right once every three
months i don't know
no i work with you the most you be
taking selfies
who's most like their character eddie
i have no defense eddie eddie
charming boy next door he's so henry
tony
would be up there as well i feel like
he's very much like dennis
dennis is you know very well to do
and tony says a lot of well to do things
i offered him a ritz cracker that had
cheese in it
and he was like i'm sorry i only cheese
in europe
all right it's okay so first of all this
is completely out of context all right
and i will explain this all right i
don't eat cheese because i don't enjoy
the taste of cheese which i
understand is weird when i'm in europe i
i actually i feel like the cheese there
for whatever reason
is very tasty but in america for some
reason it tastes very pungent and
frankly like garbage to me sometimes so
i try to avoid it like the plague in
america i know it's horrible who's the
least like their character
i said kang because her actual self
she's an open book
and she's like the nicest human being i
guess in contrast
uh melee is you know she she has some
secrets
yvonne yvonne vanessa oh they're both
good answers yvonne
as far as we can tell is not a homicidal
murderer maniac person who's best at
doing impressions of their other cast
members olivia dave we all say olivia
yeah
yeah olivia olivia olivia i'm here i'm
ready
the pressure is on i'm rolling away
john impression would be like yeah no
yeah yeah
no yeah yeah yeah no and like i'm
australian
yeah you know what i remember you know
what yeah
this is eddie uh if you offer him uh
something to eat this is him
eddie do you want um some cookies oh
no i'm good thank you just the nicest
way to reject someone he really takes
you on a ride eddie has this uh tendency
to have a difficult time saying no to
people he'll tell
you all the reasons why he would commit
to doing something that you're asking
him about
and then he'll say but maybe next time
will you guys do impressions of me
that was the one that i had i just i'm
not allowed to do that i think i would
lose my job over that right now
yeah i think i was thinking of the exact
same one if i were to physically do it
she would often kick out my knee from
behind and make me buckle
oh and then on late nights when she's
losing her mind she'll turn around and
just do
this one
that means we got to burp her we got
about she wants to burp like oh sorry
we got to pat the back yeah exactly so
it doesn't come out mid-sentence i'm a
professional
thank you i will never forget what
you've said about me thank you buzzfeed
and don't forget to check out kung fu on
the cw
wednesdays at 8pm
you